gentlemen see you tomorrow
I'll do push-ups for him you said we're
a team
one person struggles and we all struggle
one player triumphs we all triumph right
that's not that we said that we would go
in once a month every month and we
haven't done April yet yeah now we said
no wetsuits but serious for you I guess
I'll make an exception
let's make the pose
I leave tomorrow I have to go back to
school hmm you know I mean nothing my
commitments up in twelve months and then
I'm back for good
a lot can happen in 12 months John on
the Overson thing and then I'll be back
for good
you can
when he puts you in the choke move
you're gonna go to sleep it's that easy
what are you saying I think you know
what I'm saying
no I don't know what you're saying it
sounds like you saying you want me to
throw it well whatever you want to call
it you know but we're gonna make some
money not like up in the Bronx who you
complaining about that whole thing right
I'm I'm not losing I know we're not
gonna lose you're gonna do what I'm
telling listen I appreciate everything
you did for me but you know the only way
I'm gonna lose is if somebody beats me
wherever you add today you just
disappeared brand my psycho ex hand bolt
oh my god then what oh yeah I hope you
don't mind it I've done a bard one of
your your yeah and you're right by the
way these things actually work
how do you do how do you call it an
airstrike
whatever can I bring what about one of
those like package things I'm bleeding
out and I need you to spread you use a
package dinging I can bring you one pack
who is shooting what is what I'm
bleeding out right there and you are you
crawling I'm gonna crawl to victory
that's what I'm gonna do
yeah